here is a movie that screams holiday
love actually it turns 15 today I know
and for one of its stars Hugh Grant well
it's actually a painful reminder is now
iconic dance moves
I remember this terrible black cloud
hanging over the whole thing this scene
where I had to dance by myself in
Downing Street to do it cold by yourself
at 7 o'clock in the morning is not a
prospect I relish but I got there et is
taking you back to the 2003 set of the
ensemble Christmas rom-com co-starring
Emma Thompson Liam Neeson and the then
18 year old Keira Knightley husband and
wife it's a bit of a love triangle
really you know Peter and Juliet look
like they have the perfect romance
really and and then it turns out that
mark Peters best friend actually is
completely madly in love that it's
ripped
bill nye says he never was the same
after playing this washed out rocker
there was a very big day when I stand in
front of a fake mountain with fake snow
and I'm surrounded by extremely
beautiful young women in Santa Claus
outfits and I haven't really recovered I
see Martine McCutcheon played Prime
Minister Grant's love interest
she told ET a secret about filming their
kissing scene we had a natural Aldean
there that didn't know that when the
curtain falls that we would be kissing
everybody was like ah and they filmed
everybody's genuine reactions when it
happened they're like oh my god that's
Martine McCutcheon Hugh Grant kissing
what's going on right so not quite as
secret as we'd hoped
[Music]